chronique des jours qu'ovide 19 10 c'est
le titre de la collection d'une
trentaine d'oeuvres composé par et mao
le peintre et emmanuel ce corail qui est
écrivain essaya gasgoo saga tsongo
pardon d'un score cette collection
unique donc va être mise en vente par
art partage point com qui est donc une
société qui est basée à montigny le
bretonneux
oui c'est ça la chronique des jours que
8,19 days est le fruit d'une
collaboration entre ces deux artistes
ans que vous venez de citer justin en
fait cette chronique présente de
nombreux portraits de femmes et d'hommes
qui ont plus ou moins subi la crise
sanitaire toujours accompagnée d'un
texte qui contextualise le portrait ce
sont des médecins les infirmières avec
le match ce sont des personnes de tous
les jours ce sont des enfants des
adolescents des personnes manquent
toujours de vie qui subit quelque part
cette histoire dubinsky qui a
complètement envahi le monde et donc
comment eux ces chroniques ont débuté
ces liens et l'irl aventure commence le
8 avril lorsque et mao le fait le
portrait de la reine d'angleterre après
sa prise de parole concernant la crise
mondiale intitulée the queen the speech
l'oeuvre fait le buzz sur la toile et
incite donc les deux artistes à
concevoir cette collection c'est
vraiment une collaboration très
interactive déjà dans la conception et
la création de l'oeuvre
on est dans une co-construction on
arrive déjà à voir à l'oeuvre et en même
temps que l'oeuvre a été réalisée
je m'empare est du travail pour cette
fois-ci construire le texte qui allait
accompagner et comment va se passer à la
vente
eh bien c'est la société impulsion
portant le concept d'art partage point
com qui s'occupera de la vente
le but justement d'art partage points
comme mettre en lien des artistes et des
entreprises et démocratiser l'accès à
l'art dans tous types de sociétés à la
vente des puits draps débutera donc dans
les prochains jours chaque oeuvre va
être mise en scène lorraine l'univers et
cet univers dont le savez une exposition
en ligne quelques pas avec une mise à
disposition du catalogue puisque on a
préparé nous avons préparé un catalogue
en français et en anglais
donc on peut d'ores et déjà retrouver la
collection sur le site internet
art partage points comme voilà il faut
la retrouver ici et puis sur le site
internet aussi c'est noté et donc petite
particularité 30% du montant de ses
ventes donc seront reversés à
l'association l'association solidarité
avec les soignants oui c'est ça en fait
ce qui équivaut à plus ou moins à 5000
euros reversés à l'association qui a été
créée en mars 2020 par anne roumanoff et
jean pierre bansard un solidarité avec
les soignants vise à améliorer
l'équipement des salles de repos des
soignants merci célia gars tsongo
journalistes pour tv 78 d'avoir été avec
nous